ja das fragen lotto wir haben uns also
keine mühen und kosten gescheut ja auch
die roten ordentlich rein zu schmeißen
ich habe schon mal gehört also die roten
sind ja dann doch eher die unangenehmen
fragen und ist es jetzt wie beim lose
ziehen wirklich dass ich sagen dafür
ganz aussuchen du kannst du die grünen
ziehen du kannst aber auch blind ziehen
du kannst aber auch nur die roten ziehen
die aber ja da eben schon gesagt habe
dass ich in der ein oder anderen
situation auch mal mutig bin ich doch
jetzt mal eine rote gut die sind halt
das sind so die typischen klischees
fragen also die ich nie gesagt hätte
wenn die fragen die man ihm in der wüste
ist was er will
sie kommen mit diesem fall auch aus
meinem kopf aber ich gucke auch in den
kommentaren und lese viel und dann setzt
sich das so langsam ist also gewinnen
kann hier nichts gewinnen kann zwar
schade nur erfahrung an daran was denn
andere leute die ich wohl fragen würden
wenn sie einmal dürften in dem fall auch
eine sehr interessante frage warum
eigentlich nicht also die frage lautet
hast du jemals wirklich geliebt auf
jeden fall und ich finde liebe ist auch
das was das leben wirklich ausmacht also
auf jeden fall also ich hatte auch schon
mal eine siebenjährige beziehung gut da
war ich noch sehr jungen aber
nichtsdestotrotz man muss ja auch nicht
immer unter innerhalb einer
partnerschaft leben also ich liebe
meinen hund ich liebe meine mutter ich
liebe meine oma über alles und das ist
natürlich ein gefühl was berge versetzen
kann also insofern definitiv ja wenn du
dich verliebst dann kann derjenige sich
ganz sicher sein
er kann also wer erwähne ich mich
verliebe auf jeden fall kann er sich
ganz sicher sein natürlich muss das
natürlich im einklang miteinander seiner
mir ist es auch immer sehr wichtig dass
man in einer partnerschaft auf augenhöhe
zueinander ist wenn ich das gefühl habe
dass ich das ist nicht so der fall ist
dann ja gut dann zeigen wir vielleicht
selber auch an sich zu hinterfragen oder
ist wenn er ist ja partner wirklich
ehrlich zu allem und dann bröckelt das
natürlich manchmal so ein bisschen aber
vom grundsatz her auf jeden fall
ich glaube auch ich bleibe noch mal bei
einer roten okay dann wieder eine grüne
zur entspannung demokrat anbieter
per twitter kommen auch einige sein
könnte okay was du machst du dich nicht
zum affen
warum sollte ich das tun aufgrund dessen
weil ich ich sag mal du appelliert mit
dem äußeren an den niedersten männlichen
instinkten ja was ist damit gemeint gut
aber da könnte ich direkt gegen
argumentieren ich meine sex ist eines
unserer grundbedürfnisse genauso wie
essen und trinken da gibt es eine ganz
bestimmte pyramide also das gehört quasi
zu unserem täglichen bedarf glaube ich
nicht dass ich mich da zum affen macht
vor allem bin ich nicht everybodys fass
mich an
also insofern ich wecken natürlich
illusionen oder ups der vergangenheit
gemacht oder vielleicht jetzt auch immer
noch aber ich denke damit tue ich
niemanden weh und ich persönlich
empfinde das auch nicht so dass ich mich
dadurch irgendwie zum affen macht oder
dass ich mich eine stufe unter irgendwie
in der stelle weil ich persönlich bin
mit mir im einklang ich habe auch nicht
das gefühl dass alle leute mit dem
finger auf mich zeigen also das gefühl
habe ich definitiv nicht also mache ich
ganz gut
ok jetzt begleitete projekt erholung sie
beim zirkeltraining und ist sehr
entspannt kurz auflockerung phase wie
hast du den schönheitschirurgen gefunden
der sich so perfekt der dich nach
sondershausen hat er dich so perfekt
operieren konnte naja das ist jetzt
indirekt auch schon ein kompliment nach
vielen dank wie habe ich den gefunden ja
im endeffekt kenne ich ein paar mädels
sie haben sie auch schon mal ihre brüste
machen lassen oder nicht in der
dimension wie ich es habe aber die
technik angewandt hat die fand ich ganz
interessant man munkelt ja auch dass der
herr doktor dias aus madrid auch
victoria beckham schon irgendwie zu
irgendetwas wolfen hat so was auch immer
ich möchte da jetzt nichts unterstellen
aber es ist schon bekannte
schönheitschirurg aus spanien
der ebenfalls speziell zu arbeiten
unterwegs ist und so kam einfach der
kontakt und ich habe auch inzwischen
schon das ein oder andere mal selbst
vermittelt ok dh es ist wirklich so du
hast kollegin gefunden wie hast du das
denkmal des mit 18 kindern die in der
porno also auch so meint er dass falls
er denn jetzt also die anderen waren
wohl mein erster rat sehr genau mein
erster arzt selber in deutschland das
ist in bad neuenahr und den habe ich
ganz klassisch beim durchblättern durch
durch seine zeit schrieb ich glaube das
ist die rtv gewesen hat immer in der
zeitung mit zugefügte in der
tageszeitung gibt es einmal ein mal die
woche und da habe ich die cosmos klinik
in bad neuenahr ich will natürlich keine
werbung machen die jetzt immer noch
gefunden und damals war das ja noch
nicht so ich meine das war das denn
müsste ich jetzt rechnen können so
kopfzahl mathematik oder kopfrechnen ich
glaube rechnen heutzutage ist kann sich
genau ich kann nicht stehen er also auf
die funktion und auf die unbekannten und
so weiter phoenix ist gleich und so aber
also wirklich klassisch beim
durchblättern kosmos klinik und
angerufen infomaterial zusenden lassen
damals im übrigen auch zu meiner mutter
nicht zu meiner mutter sondern zu meiner
oma das war so ein bisschen gemacht
meine mutter wusste nichts von der
ersten op habe ich ein bisschen
hintergangen weil ich keinen bock auf
diskussionen hatte es war auch nicht so
ganz fair das würde ich heute nicht mehr
machen da hättest du gern ihr leben
anders verlaufen wenn ich nicht gemacht
hätte wenn deine mutter medien
diskutiert hätte du hättest keine
brustvergrößerung soweit wenn man
wahrscheinlich nicht sitzen wer weiß wer
weiß wo ich dann dann heute wäre wie
auch immer aber ich weiß es sie hat dann
damals zu dem zeitpunkt die fotos immer
hier erst mal abgestimmt aber damals das
war ja gar nicht so schlimm damals aber
sie fand es trotzdem sie weil sie
natürlich immer sagt das ist wie kann
man sich wenn man gesund ist freiwillig
unters messer legen und dann so ein
risikofaktor mit sich herum tragen weil
dietrich wenn man fremd geworden das
kann man nicht bestehen
wer wünscht dass für seine tochter
machst du eigentlich alles für geld also
definitiv nicht ich habe sicherlich auch
schon mal
sehr unseriöse angebote von
irgendwelchen vermögenden männern
bekommen also de facto nein also gibt es
diese angebote eine million und eine
million gab es mit sicherheit noch nicht
aber also ich sag mal so im
fünfstelligen bereich auf jeden fall
mehr war sogar einmal sechsstellig nach
100 tagen 100.000 schönen urlaub und ab
geht die post
ich mache ja ich habe das gut zu wissen
ja du bist ja also ich denke jeder hat
seine ganzen aber natürlich wenn man
davon spricht man auch gerade in der
pornobranche ich finde da muss man sich
natürlich also habe ich auch gut
verhandelt nicht weil ich gesagt habe ja
ich mache jetzt die beine breit sondern
weil ich eben gerade meinen namen
hergeben oder mein image egal ob es
jetzt eben ein film oder mehrere sind in
dem moment natürlich ganz knapp lege ich
meine im zeitalter des internets
die nächste bewerbung vielleicht im
immobilienbereich könnte schwierig
werden ein mal gegoogelt weil in meinem
lebenslauf wird auch drinstehen was ich
gemacht habe
na ja und wenn da steht medien brauchen
sehr gut sein beides elwert aber man
kommt immer drauf klar da wird man immer
wieder mit aufkommen warum bist du
erfolgreicher als andere porno stars bin
ich darf die wir kennen sich also das
kennen die sehr viele menschen und das
kann man von vielen pornostars nicht
sagen was ihr auch gut ist ja also ich
sag mal so natürlich ist es so die
pornobranche ist so ein eigener kleiner
bereich wie so ein kleines aquarium für
sich
das was da drinnen passiert schwappt nur
sehr selten rüber in die mainstream
medien weil natürlich eben gerade auch
jugendschutz und so weiter das ist ja
mal so ein schwieriges thema gut bei mir
lag es vielleicht so ein bisschen auch
daran dass ich was ich lese eingezogen
bin ich da im endeffekt die plattform
hatte mich auch als normaler mensch in
anführungsstrichen aber ich wäre auch
noch mal zeigen zu dürfen nicht nur als
dieser porno als diese pornodarstellerin
ich hab natürlich wirklich sehr wenig
filme gedreht im vergleich zu anderen ja
die müssen sich da geht nicht mehr durch
nudeln lassen und trotzdem effekt
na ja das stimmt schon aber da gibt es
ja es ist ein hartes karriereende ist es
ja eine porno industrie wenn du
irgendwann zu alt wird dann ist halt
manchmal gut es gibt natürlich auch
diese milch schienen aber man das ist
ein echter liebhaber aber ich meine ich
bin ja nun auch schon alles das muss ich
ganz klar sagen also nicht am set war
und die 18 19 20 jährigen tschechien
oder so gegner auch gerne hier in
deutschland gedreht haben da stehen dann
sagt man sich auch okay da kannst du
noch mal 10 10 15 jahre drauf packen da
also das ist natürlich auch für mich
immer eine herausforderung gewesen aber
ich habe irgendwann mal versucht
authentisch zu bleiben und nicht
irgendwie eines show oder das nach dem
schema f abzuwickeln sondern wirklich da
stars vor der kamera zu haben und das
haben natürlich die einen oder anderen
leute dann auch gesehen und das kommt
natürlich an oder sowas natürlich dann
auch honoriert das ist ein bisschen
erotik dabei ja auch wenn man dann echt
bleibt irgendwie tut noch eine zum
abschluss eine zum abschluss noch eine
rote grüne schlossen dagegen hast du
nicht mehr drauf als nur die beine breit
zu machen
doch ich würde sagen auf jeden fall ich
hab natürlich eine zeit lang durch
meinen meine exklusivvertrag mein geld
oder meinen lebensunterhalt verdient ist
ganz klar und da gab es dann auch die
ein oder andere sexuelle handlung auf
jeden fall aber nichtsdestotrotz würde
ich sagen das ist viel mehr nach außen
sieht es immer noch aus also ich mache
meine komplette buchhaltung selber ich
mache meine reiseplanung selber ja ich
buch meine flüge und so weiter und so
fort ich meine es ist jetzt keine
glanzleistung aber natürlich muss man
organisiert sein und auch denke ich mal
sehr professionell
bei ansonsten ist man tag lang
interessant und auch brüste alleine
bringt einen nicht
die zwei jahre irgendwie in die medien
weil es ist wirklich todlangweilig also
sicher auch selber so also ich kann es
ja manchmal seien wahrscheinlich mehr zu
sehen
und wenn dann immer die gleichen
beiträge kommen aber das ist natürlich
auch so dass es vom fernsehen manchmal
so gewünscht ist gehört es gab absolut
natürlich also die stoffe sicher quasi
drauf und ich habe das oft auch schon
erlebt dass sie dann sagen so auch
mensch da kannst du nicht ein bisschen
ordinärer sei nicht so ne kann ich jetzt
gerade nicht weil das bin ich einfach
nicht das ist ein teil von mir aber
deswegen muss ich ja nicht eine ausnahme
sein
also von daher ich würde schon sagen
dass ich mehr drauf habe als nur meine
beine breit wobei du deine karriere
schon auf erstens dein äußeres setzt du
sagst ja ich trete mauer oberbayern ohne
sehen zu können ja also du machst nicht
wo du sagst ich habe ich eine fähigkeit
und die baue ich aus ja das ist deine
fähigkeit oder ist doch eine ganz
bestimmte fähigkeit die ich jetzt
vielleicht gar nicht sehe dahinter gut
ich würde schon sagen auch generell auf
mallorca können sehr wenig leute
wirklich gut singen das hat ja auch da
hat sich das ein bisschen verändert da
einfach so das ist einfach entertainment
pur na und ich möchte natürlich keine
kollegen angreifen aber es ist so nah
also das haben ja auch einige gesagt
aber nichtsdestotrotz würde ich schon
sagen
also ich persönlich sehe mich auf jeden
fall anders na das ist ja das ist auch
eine verzerrte wahrnehmung aber ich
würde schon sagen dass ich definitiv
mehr kann und dass ich jetzt auch ihm
nicht nur darauf ausgelegt habe weil ich
hätte zum beispiel auch eine clubtour
durch ganz deutschland machen können mit
irgendwelchen erotik schaus und was eben
hat auch wirklich viele darsteller was
ist so klassisch in dem bereich
irgendwelche dildos und so weiter und so
fort
und da muss ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen
das wollte ich nicht habe ich auch
unendlich viel geld verschenken so gehen
auch noch mal zum thema macht so viel
geld alles mit sicherheit nicht jetzt
mehr verdienen ja auf jeden fall muss
ich dabei auch wohlfühlen und irgendwie
in der diskothek ja wo die leute dann
weil sie nichts homölle und aufwärts
haben irgendwie mich da auszuziehen und
beine breit zu machen
das werde ich in dem moment eine show
gewesen weil bei 15 minuten kann ich
jetzt auch nicht so habe ich da
die super lustig wie auf einer bühne die
beine breit zu machen also das brauche
ich dann auch nicht wirklich aber das
muss auch da jeder selbst für sich
entscheiden es gibt sicherlich genug
darstellerin die das so praktizieren
weil es ja auch eine gute einnahmequelle
ist auf jeden fall aber für mich war es
dann doch ein wie das sage ich brauchte
dann irgendwie meinen meinen rahmen und
auch nicht dieses ja diese diesen
abstand dann auch zu den leuten also
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise im
fernsehen meine brüste zeit ist es für
mich als anderes als wenn ich das
zwischen tausenden von leuten mache weil
ich bin dann in dem nun von leuten ich
bin ja aber ich bin ich bin in dem
moment trotz alledem unnahbar war also
da kann ja jetzt was ich mal an das ist
für mich dann doch eher in dem moment
die illusion die ich dann verkaufe weil
wie gesagt anfassen als solches in dem
moment keiner
ok dann vielen dank sehr gerne